oh man i'm glad to be back
you know it's uh february 2021.
and um i just had a birthday uh early
this month
uh february the 18th and uh i turned 54
years old
never thought i would get here
and that's a blessing
and sometimes if i feel like it's a
curse and i'm just bullshitting
no but but for real for real um
you know and i always getting to this
stage of the game
uh to being
and i've never been committed to
anything not in relationships
personal relationships jobs
um and anything else except
when it came to making a commitment to
the [ __ ] gym
that's the only thing that i've been
committed to
and i've been a partner with for the
past 30 years
i hooked up a crack cocaine that [ __ ]
lasted a while it was back and forth in
it all
but i wasn't committed to it it didn't
last as long as this
committed to going to prison did that
[ __ ] about 19 times
i don't know how many years that have
sucked the [ __ ] up out of me that my
life in that area
uh rehabs 30 of them [ __ ]
you know but i didn't make that kind of
commitment to those places
like i did to the gym overall
the gym that's what carried me through
that's what came through
when the [ __ ] hit the fan when all
that's filled
there's always some things that take
place man in my life where i really have
to take a step back
and take a look and say hmm i get it
or i understand now
or it's like somebody hit the light
switch and the light comes on
and i said oh i understand now
and that's where the gym comes in that
i remember man i started
this commitment to working out
just so i could be able to take care of
myself
growing up i was always tall
i was skinny and um
i didn't get picked on as far as like by
bullies
but i had a hard time at it man you know
just dealing with um my sibling
you know had an older brother chip on
his [ __ ] shoulder
and uh eight out of ten times he took it
out on me
and i think i endured that [ __ ] from
like
eight nine years old till
maybe i was
17 years old so say 19 19 years old to
up to 17 that was the day that i took my
first trip
to the state penitentiary so um
i remember back then i had called a
strong armed robbery
they sentenced me to 16 months i was 17
at the time
going and going turning to 18. said he
said okay
by the time you turn 18 your ass you'll
be right for prison
because in order to go to the state
penitentiary you have to be 18 years
older
17 years or less that's juvenile hall
juvie
and um so i was right man for that
but lo and behold man i got the i got
the prison
my ass up there to jamestown went to
[ __ ] fire camp
had i was up in the mountains in the
cabins eating like a king
and guess what they had up in there
waiting on me weights
i was in heaven i enjoyed that [ __ ] i
went right
back again in under two years
next time he said me they sent me with
four years
i couldn't wait to get back because they
had everything that i've ever imagined
that i didn't have on the streets i had
up in here
a safe haven a place to get away from
everything and every [ __ ] body
including myself
but what was integral about that whole
experience was the
weights man it was the transformation
that took place
now the transformation the
transformation didn't take place
mentally psychologically or spiritually
the transformation took place physically
i was transformed from a scrawny little
kid to like the
god is my witness the [ __ ]
incredible hulk
i left that i left the prison so big i
didn't even
i didn't even recognize myself my family
even did the double take they couldn't
even believe it
and that's what set the ball rolling and
that's was that's
and that's that one
guiding force has been leading the way
thus far for the past 30 something years
transformation i didn't see it
but other people saw them before i could
see them myself and then when i finally
got around to seeing it for what the
[ __ ] it was
i couldn't even believe it
who me you got to be kidding me
cause i've always been skinny i've
always been
thin fast you know fast with my feet and
all that [ __ ] condensed real good
and all that
catch the football real good
[Music]
i remember i remember being a kid
we used to climb we just going to alley
stack about six seven mattresses man we
climb up the damn telephone pole get on
the tallest roof
and jump off the roof into the mattress
and flip
i'm talking about three four stories man
and you know how dangerous that was but
back then it wasn't nothing to us
man because we just needed something to
do
that was it i remember running in and
burning buildings and all that [ __ ]
in disguise or going in there to save a
cat or a dog or a little baby or
something
wasn't nothing in there that was just we
had to think of something in order to do
some crazy [ __ ] like that
and that's what we did that's what i did
as a kid
you know [ __ ] like that man
running through traffic and all that
[ __ ] trying not to get hit
like like like the game uh uh you're it
that's that's what i did man
when i recognized the transformation for
what it was
it changed everything about me the way i
thought the way i feel the way i saw
myself
well they didn't change that part to
where i saw myself because
by then i was consumed
or i was taken in by what other people
saw of me with other people's perception
was so i got lost i got lost in the
in the other people's appraisal and
and accolades and all that [ __ ]
so um in other words i was lost in the
sauce
before i even know what it was
i come home after 10 months of fur camp
swollen in a [ __ ] didn't do
nothing with it got back into the same
old [ __ ]
caught another robbery went back for
four years would have
did about 20 26 months or some days
came out twice as big twice as strong
twice as fast like the six uh the bionic
man six million dollar man bigger
stronger faster
hell yeah that was me in full effect
and um what happened was i didn't want
to go right back
so um
i looked up into something that helped
me
kind of keep me on the straight narrow
and um
at the time when i was coming up they
had uh ymcas ywcas and all that kind of
stuff
and um this was back in the 80s back in
the
back in the early 90s i think um 24
fitness had just came out
so i was gone i think i went to prison
back in
89 and i upper road in like 91
close to 1992 and
uh 24 fitness uh hill clubs is out there
man the gyms and i'm like man
you know let me sign up and that's
exactly what i did
and i've been dealing with the 24
fitness now 30 plus years
we have this relationship that is so
it's crazy man
i didn't take advantage of the gym like
a like a shutter i didn't use it for
what what i'm what what it helps me for
now back then i was just using it for
just the outside because that's all that
mattered to me i didn't give a [ __ ]
about nothing but the outside
what the [ __ ] you thought how you feel
on everything i'd be in a relationship
with a woman man
you know if i'm laying there if i'm
laying the dick good
if i'm staying i'm swollen in a
[ __ ] gym and
and if i'm doing everything i'm supposed
to be doing to make her happy then i'm
cool i'm in heaven
but let me not meet one of her
expectations
let me disappoint her in some shape form
of fashion
now i'm walking around like a piece of
[ __ ] like the weight of the world is on
my shoulders
it's a beautiful day but this dark cloud
is hovering around me
where the [ __ ] does that come from i
didn't have a clue
because my worth was based on somebody's
purse
by some other person's perspective of me
man how they saw me was i saw my
[ __ ] self i couldn't see me
back then
i was lost back then man [ __ ]
i was invisible man up until just
recently i've always been an invisible
man
i never saw who was looking back at me
in the reflection in the [ __ ]
mirror
even way back then i wouldn't admit it
back then like i can admit it today man
i
there's so much more to it than that but
i'ma keep it on the gym
so my worth was based on how other
people saw me man
because i couldn't see me back then all
i knew
i found something that worked that got
me a lot of attention
and it was good attention it was
attention that made me feel like a king
on the throne
remember walking down the street my
thugs doing a double take
man i just this man used to light me up
on the inside but i wouldn't show it you
wouldn't know it
she used to kill me i remember just
laying in bed at night
going over the days the days comings and
goings and all my little
places that i've been and then different
people's reaction man i'll be sleeping
i'll be laughing and
tossing and turning giggling kicking my
feet and flopping around like like a a
fish out of water
you know with just that jubilation man
of the effect that i caused
that [ __ ] it was crazy i swear to god
god is my witness and i use the gym
for what it was worth man and it got me
through a lot of hardships it got me
through a lot of scrapes and a lot of
man i used a gem
in my body to get me through through my
20s
30s and 40s so that means i have to rely
on the gym where
i didn't graduate from high school but i
had that [ __ ] gym
i don't i i i didn't have a work history
but i had the [ __ ] gym
i had crack on my [ __ ] back
like like his king kong but i had the
gym
my life was totally in ruins man but i
had the gym
so i thought the gym would solve all my
problems in all those areas
and it took me man
a lot of trips to prison to figure out
the gym wouldn't solve that
a lot of trips to rehab to figure out
the gym couldn't save me from that
a lot of trips to being homeless to
realize the gems couldn't
keep me from going near
because i was using the jump for the
wrong reasons man
i wasn't using it to help me in the ways
that it was meant to
i was using that [ __ ] to build up the
outside what was killing my
[ __ ] ass on the inside was me
not looking at me man for who i was man
for the things i didn't do that i should
have done
so i'm using the gm as my [ __ ]
scapegoat
or if it wasn't for the gym i probably
would have been dead or if it wasn't for
the gym i probably would but then
probably would have been this or that
the gym only did what was supposed to do
man
and that was to give me something that i
didn't have man
but it was real because the
transformation
did take place i just wasn't ready to
accept it for what it was
i'ma share something with you this [ __ ]
is deep i've been in the gym 30
[ __ ] years
i had the opportunity to train four
people
four people in my 37 years
and i saw the transformation take place
in a [ __ ] life so i know it's
real
that's my gift
they didn't say them for no
[ __ ] horror ships they didn't
save them from from broken marriages or
whatever
whatever the case or or bankruptcy or
some [ __ ] like that
because it had nothing to do with that
i got to see the transformation take
place
it's like the [ __ ] caterpillar going
into the to the corn and turn it coming
out as the butterfly
that kind of transformation i got to see
it
and that's real that's my gift
that's what i owe to the gym
i don't walk around with no billboards
i'm a trainer and all that [ __ ] i don't
have no [ __ ] cars made up
personal training will train you and all
that [ __ ]
we'll train you for food and some [ __ ]
like that
on the side of the [ __ ] freeway
with the sign we'll train for food
or for money or crack or whatever ain't
that kind of party
i don't i don't put it out there
if you happen to see
me in a gym or any [ __ ] world
else and you want to get together and
partner up
then i'm willing i'll i'll do it you
know
i'll take you up on your offer
because i know if i don't train nobody
else
while i'm on this earth then god won't
be mad at me
because i help four people
you know how many people helped me over
the years or tried to
in other areas where the transformation
did take place
transformation that [ __ ] is so important
but the cool thing about it
it doesn't take a whole bunch of people
it's that one-on-one kind of
transformation thing you got to do
you got to have you have to experience
it my transformation happened in prison
with one [ __ ] man
you didn't take the whole [ __ ]
yard you didn't take the self-classes
church islamic services
education and all that [ __ ]
training [ __ ] on the yard it
didn't take all that
one person me dealing with him
and it happened god damn it in this reel
so i know it's real the [ __ ] i'm talking
about i've been in the game long enough
to see it for what it is
i was just using it for the wrong reason
the transformation is so real so serious
with me
i get a lot of people asking questions
at the gym on the streets
check this out i remember in prison
have so many people coming up to me oh
man i want to work out with y'all man i
want to train with you know that
[ __ ]
now mind you my last trip to prison i
did like six and a half years
on one yard went away for a minute and
came back but that
that's that's frivous but for the most
part man i was in one spot
and before i parole from that
[ __ ] i was training i was
training three different dudes
and it took up seven days of the week so
i stayed busy
i stayed on yours seven days a week
working out stayed in education did the
sale prep classes church islamic
services and all that other [ __ ]
that came with it
oh can't forget worked in the kitchen
mind you
i'm training seven days a week but
before i can
lock in that four the the three people
that took up the seven days a week for
me
leading up to our parole from that
[ __ ]
i experienced hundreds of men doing that
six and a half years all i want to work
out y'all want to train with you and all
that [ __ ]
come on board man i got you make me hear
me be there meet me out there
go through a workout session might not
see them the next day might not seem for
another [ __ ] week
you know how many scores of men tapped
out
early in the game because they thought i
was bullshitting
thought i wasn't serious about my
[ __ ] craft or my gift
see i didn't know i had to give back
then i thought my gift was the dick the
pipe
the anaconda whatever [ __ ] you want to
call it the body
i don't know my gift was much more than
that
so leading up until i parole
in 2017 once that transformation took
place everything
came full circle and i knew just exactly
how important
working out helped me through those
trials and errors
of those [ __ ] trips to prison
and those trips to rehab
and those many countless vain attempts
man and getting my
[ __ ] together but still ended up on the
side of a [ __ ] freeway off ramp
out there in the san fernando valley
i see where the gym was important back
then i see where it came in and helped
me
navigate and deal with that [ __ ] even
though i wasn't trying to see it for
what it was
because i was invisible man back then
but that gym was that gym was
real that's the only [ __ ] thing
that sustained me through those trips to
prison
through those rehabs man and those
homeless encounters man
it was a [ __ ] gym that was the
only thing that was the only thing that
i had solid to stand on
and it's still to test the timing is
still doing it today
more so than ever i rely on it more now
than ever
because it's real
you know how long it took me to realize
the real transformation that took place
in my [ __ ] life
i'm not gonna even see it i'll be
embarrassed and you guys will be shocked
so i'm gonna keep that to myself you
know more will be revealed
but for the most part my body and spirit
it encompasses all those things
like i said more so now than ever
so the transformation took place in
prison for me
and once i saw it for what it was and
once it hit me
and i saw where we're training fit in
what part that playing in it
i secured three men
seven days a week i have one for two
days one for two days and one for three
days
and prior to that
guys was just one week here two three
days with me
four uh uh uh four days here maybe eight
nine days
uh working out with me and tap out and
all that kind of [ __ ]
but after that metamorphosis
with this one man
i parole i had to say
korean guy mr lee
you know i love mr lee you know
because he was always there on time
and um i hated mr lee too
because mr lee had money big money
and i remember when he first
approached me and we were talking and
after he left people was like hey man
you know what that was
i said yeah mr lee they said no that no
that [ __ ] is a millionaire i'm
like what you mean
see man he's the one that look he he's
like a um
he he had those places like the um those
[ __ ] smoothies those berry smoothies
and um but he sold his um he sold his
whatever [ __ ] you call it we have more
than one his franchise
his franchises before he came to prison
got millions for it
i said okay but i feel bad
because he didn't tell me that leading
up to me
making this um um finalizing our little
a little deal with you know how much i
would charge him every month to uh to
train them man
and uh i said well check this out mr lee
i chose you 48
a month just to trade you man how many
days a week i don't give a [ __ ] man i'll
be out here you know
just let me know he said let's try four
on three off i said okay
and um
what's what what what made me mad was he
didn't tell me who he was beforehand
over the church a whole lot more than 40
dollars man
see that's where that real
transformation take place because you
really know you're worth them
i know my [ __ ] word i know it
wasn't your average joe when it came to
training i don't know i had a gift in
that area
[ __ ] but what happened was he flipped
the script on me right
so after about one year
of being committed to my [ __ ]
training this this how he paid me back
he would give me he he said okay give me
your list for the store for the 40 bucks
but every every quarterly package he
said eric
um what kind of tennis shoes would you
like um
for this quarter man pick up pick up
your period i'm gonna [ __ ] how much it
costs
give me a pair of tennis when they had
the food sales i don't care what it was
every food sale
what you want from the full cell man
man i take the i say um sam was in and
out man give me the double give me the
double
the double burger with the fries in the
shake and and throwing some cookies on
the side
and he would do it pizza same thing
order a whole pizza for me
chicken the whole the whole chicken
you know he did that for me so it wasn't
that he was shortchanging me no
i got mine on the back end but that was
what was important because
i didn't think he saw my work but he did
so even though he said check this out
eric
the only reason why i never paid you
more than the 40 you asked for in the
beginning
because i'm a businessman
and i stick to my word he said so i had
to show you i
i'm teaching you in business always
get that [ __ ] out in the front where
that whatever it is wherever you see
yourself
then let them know if they accept it
cool if not then you're going about your
business
he said i'm a businessman i had you know
that
that's what you told me 40 bucks he said
i'm cool with that
he said i don't mind paying more money
but
i'mma keep you he said i'm gonna keep
you um
i'm gonna keep you what was that word it
was the same needs to say back then uh
i'm gonna keep you something man
anyway man i'm gonna keep you honest in
that area man
you know so he said but next time don't
never
don't ever say no [ __ ] like that no
forty dollars man
he said cause that's really he said it's
not in their soul but he says just by me
being with you for about a year
man money king this money can't pay what
the transformation is taking place and
what he meant by that was he says
i think after maybe the first three
months
you know he's married and everything she
used to do those family business in
prison
but he said his wife noticed the
transformation taking place
she knows the separation from the
shoulders she knows the little
muscles in his back doing a little uh
uh love sessions and um
i think after six months man after six
months he loves training
he said hey eric man my wife told me to
tell you thank you man
and uh he broke down i said man what you
breaking down for
because he said my wife was showing she
just couldn't believe it man
i said he says i've been my wife over 20
years
he said she ain't never reacted like
that
she was never that she never was really
that surprised
when it came to touching and feeling all
that stuff he said she was so into the
touching and the feelings
and exploring me by the different body
parts
he says man it blew my mind man and
that's when he
knew that the transformation was real
because he couldn't see it
but she did she said tell that
[ __ ] i said thank you
and she meant it and when he told me i
knew he meant it
and it probably took a lot for him to
even confide that [ __ ] to me him
you have to understand man being in
prison and having that kind of money
he had a lot of minions running around
that [ __ ]
he had somebody washing his clothes he
had somebody holding his phones
he had about 70 lockers up in that
[ __ ] full of stuff
so we had a lot of people doing this
bidding
so it took a it took a lot for him to
to expose himself to me like that in
that area
but he had no choice
[ __ ] because it was real
that's when i knew i know my gift i know
my gift
that's just one example that's just one
man
but he lasted 18 months with me on a
regular basis
and the day i paroled he was right there
with me there parole we was out there
on the yard training
the day before i parole out there with
me
and i remember up until maybe i paroled
in 2017 i remember
maybe a year or two afterwards i might
see men that i was in prison with
and they said hey man you're the trainer
hey man you you i'll remember you man
you was the [ __ ] working out
seven days a week on the yard
and they said tell me hey man the seals
and did say somebody i'll still be
talking about you man using you as a
reference
a lot of inmates was talking about you
on the yard using you as a reference man
remember that black dude man the tall
black dude
and i knew right then and there that
me being in prison me having that
transformation take place
i left something good on that
[ __ ] i didn't leave that
[ __ ] with my reputation perceive
me in a negative way
i left there with my reputation
perceived me in a good way
[ __ ] was referring to me as a
trainer not no [ __ ]
your son yeah i'm not no trainer yes i
am i'm not no trainer
i'm not gonna buy that but see that was
a reference to me and i almost bit into
it
but i didn't because that's not what i
was there for
training is one thing but the
transformation is
is something different entirely man and
if you if you get that [ __ ] twisted then
you'll never get past point a to point b
that's why i was stuck in point a for so
[ __ ] long because
even though the transformation took
place i was stuck in the mindset of a
trainer
so it didn't help me mind body and
spirit it just helped me in the physical
from the outside look from the outside
perspective but there was so much more
to it than that
once the transformation takes place and
i know man it's not about the training
it's about what happens once that
happens your whole [ __ ] life
change everything changes
not just on the physical on how you see
yourself
it's not so much on how other people
view you or what other [ __ ] say
about you but it's how you see yourself
and what you say
about yourself to yourself that's the
transformation right there
and where does it help you out outside
of the body
you know and i got a small taste of that
man from mr lee
mr lee was an architect so
he would get me on the weekends to come
to the arts and crafts class
and he'd be showing me these different
designs and all that kind of stuff i'd
be like
oh my god you know man how did you learn
this in college oh my bad
that's above my pay scale so those are
conversations we didn't have
you know because he was on a whole
another level man
but when that transformation happened he
dropped it down to my [ __ ]
level so i can get a sneak peek at what
he was dealing with he said you know
what eric
when i come home i want to hire you man
i want to get you hooked up with me so i
can open up some kind of enterprise to
get you in there somewhere
fit you in there somewhere where i can
help you
mr lee wants to help me when he gets out
of prison
succeed because of what i did in there
for him
because it wasn't about no [ __ ]
training that wasn't that it was a
transformation
he got it i got it
it's more than trainer it's how you see
things everything you see is different
you might be going through the same [ __ ]
you might be going through the same
thing in prison
or in a relationship on your job and
that kind of stuff but the way you see
it is different
that's the transformation then you know
it's real
it took my partner curtis
close to three years of dealing with me
101 for that transformation to take
place
it took mr lee about nine months of me
working one-on-one with him
through training for him for that
transformation to take place
so it's different for everybody and it
works in all kinds of skill sets i don't
give a [ __ ] what it is
mind body and spirit that transformation
can take place in each and every area
all all is one or one or individually
you know it's different strokes for
different folks you know
you have to run across that one person
that one man or woman that that you meet
or your accountant
like man god damn baby
i'll change every [ __ ] thing
for you i won't rob i'm gonna steal i'm
gonna cheat i'm gonna do nothing
and mean that [ __ ] that's the
transformation i'm talking about
meeting that special someone
that how you do things you never thought
you'd do in your entire life
going back to school learning how to
become a truck driver
you know doing everything in your power
she makes that
make sure that she's happy she's okay
because you gave her your worth that you
would take care of her you'll be the
best man that you can be
and live up to that [ __ ]
standard back up your words through your
actions
if you've never done that your eternal
life that's the kind of transformation
i'm talking about
i think mr lee should be out
in another two years
and um i know he's gonna be true to his
word
you know he's still in there running
[ __ ] he's still a millionaire he's still
you know people still talk about
miscellane all that kind of stuff i
you know i i keep my ears you know close
to the street and
all that kind of stuff and uh i stay in
contact with some people
that go to crc once a month you know
doing those panels you know different
panels cell pill
aaa uh na those kind of those kind of
panels man
and you know i'll call every now and
then and get hey what's going on oh i
went up to crc last month and
you know every you know they let me know
what's going on
you know and um i haven't heard anything
in the world because of the cover 19
but before then you know i was getting a
monthly update on
you know what was going on with the with
the particular paper
with the particular people that i had
that close uh relationship with when it
came to the trainer
and uh mr lee he was at the top of the
list because everybody knew who he was
you know but um
the way it helped me out there was
the way it helped me in there was it got
me to see it wasn't about me
training it was about me
giving something that would make a
person
better that'll make them a better man or
a better woman
make them do do things they never
thought they'd do before or go where
they never thought they could go before
you know and it wasn't just on the train
and man because when mr lee broke it
down for me
he met me at my level he said check this
off eric i know he ain't been to school
but i would suggest this
and he run him down to me what it was
like for him being in school
when he was taking a architecture class
he broke it down to me told me
what the classes were like the time he
had to put into it the commitment and
all that [ __ ]
he even talked about his relationship
with his wife and what it meant to him
how important it was for him when he met
her he said
he was a certain kind you know he was he
was he was a tough guy because he knew
that um
a lot of agents know that was he a
kickboxer thinking he was in a
kickboxing
so he was a tough guy but she told him
she didn't want a [ __ ] that was
violent
he said he didn't he didn't do no more
no more fighting
out of anger when he met her he said he
stopped that
he didn't do no more fighting when he
came that's his thing kickboxing
he said he gave it up for her and that's
when i knew
oh the transformation's taking place oh
he had that transformation in that area
because i had mine so i recognized his
and when he shared it with me it just
confirmed everything that it just came
full circle
so i'm gonna get off the person to get
up to the to the now
i need to like the air that i breathed
man to make it through the day
got the covered [ __ ] 19 and all
that [ __ ] and
then my world's been turned upside down
um
it helps me it helps me man
when i want to go left when i want to
give up and feel sorry for myself
because i just don't
i feel like at 54 [ __ ] years
old i should be somewhere else in
another time in another place
i should be in a relationship with miss
wright
should have the house the car the kids
and all that [ __ ]
man i don't have none of that
and it's killing me because that's what
i want more than ever
never been married that's one of those
unspoken prayers
has it been answered it's killing me
that's how much i want out of life man
and it's not a whole lot because i found
what i need not just being okay with
me being uncomfortable in my own
[ __ ] skin
the good the bad and the difficult
but the jail god damn it that's my
foundation
because i know that's where
transformations take place not mine not
for my sake but for your [ __ ]
sake if you ever run across me
and you make that commitment then you'll
see what i'm talking about
because it'll be real for you like it's
a lot it'll be real for you just as much
as it's real for me
but the beautiful thing about it is i
get to
watch it take place i get to help it
come to pass [ __ ] is going to take time
it's going to take
energy it's going to take effort and all
that [ __ ] on my part
i'm going to have to show up each and
every day and give you all that i got to
give
in that area
and got the lead by example i can't just
sit on my ass and say hey you need to do
10 sessions
you need to do 10 of these or five hell
no
i'm up in that [ __ ] with you get
get behind me man i'll get your ass on
my shoulders to get on my back or
whatever
but we're about to do this that's the
kind of [ __ ] effort i'm talking
about
being right there with you every step of
the way
that's my gift that's my
that's what i have to offer today
something real
something tangible
transformation
money can't buy that you can't even put
a price on that
because that's something nobody can ever
take away from you
once it happens you can never go back
not to where you came from you'd be like
oh hell no
moving forward ahead put one foot in
because you know
that what the [ __ ] i'm talking about is
real because it's real for you
like it was real for me
everybody has their gifts man everybody
has their talents man
but to witness the transformation that's
something different entirely man
up
one is one of these days or one of these
times i i have to talk about the
transformation man
because so that's a [ __ ]
important man that's
that's that's the platform that's the
springboard for for this
this this whole new world opening up
before your eyes man
the transformation for me is like man
i'll walk
and encounter every day as a brand new
day man
up i went to the gym this morning
got back
feel so [ __ ] good cleaned my
little apartment up
listened to my music and took a shower
and laid down
i was looking at a movie and i'm sitting
in my bed
eating this uh big ass bowl of raisin
bran with sliced bananas in it right
and i'm just giggling and laughing
because i feel good all
over i feel like a million dollars
because i got to do what i love to do
what i do
best and i i did it for me
for me it's important that i set aside
some time for me
if you had a whole block full of people
wanting to be trained that was committed
god damn would i be there for each and
every one of them individually
but i still have to settle set aside
some time for me
because i need that too because it's
like the air i breathe man
it's not my foundation but i know it's
real
and what it works for me it works all
areas man
teach me from the [ __ ] keeps me out
the [ __ ]
keeps me from the places i shouldn't be
doing the things i shouldn't be doing
and the people i shouldn't be doing it
with man because i'm like this man
i get to carry some change in my pocket
today and every now and then i see
uh one of them women out there i know
she's out there out there hustling
trying to make her money
and lord knows i like to contribute to
her calls
oh hey i'm human fair exchange ain't no
robbery how much
got you girl thank you man man i'm gone
but the jail keeps me from going there
i get frustrated man so what the [ __ ] i
do when i get back from the gym take a
cold shower i should have passed
so i be on the bus in the trains and i
see a lot of those women
and someone look at me like um i'd be
like
but i know better i know what comes with
that
and i'm not willing to take that chance
so it works
in all areas i just don't have enough
time to go into detail but i think you
get the picture
it's the best thing that's ever happened
to me because i got to see it for what
it really is and what it really means
man
and how important it is when it's all
said and done it's not the [ __ ]
foundation
but it's a it's a piece of the puzzle
that brings it all together man
and i couldn't have one without the
other but then the cool thing about it
is
everything that i've experienced all the
things that's been added to my arsenal
or to my
to my uh my tools my tools my tool chest
it complements man everything
complements the other
this part complements this this part
complements that just to make this a
little bit better this part this aspect
makes us a little bit better
so everything's coming together man and
before you know it
i'm going to be inside this complete
circle and i'm going to be the little
thing
i'm going to be the one in the middle
that's surrounded by the herd
and protected and looked over
and that's exactly where i want to be in
the middle
surrounded by the things that's helping
me embolden me and making me bigger
stronger faster but in the areas where
you can't see it but i know it's there
and i know
it's real because everything that's
happening that i encounter
is for the good it's for the betterment
you know i'm adding to some [ __ ] today i
want the skills
that really pay the bills you know
i need skills that pays bills not just
by here said by word
but by action and that's what i get from
the gym it helps me man in those areas
it helps me be a better painter floor
wood finisher [ __ ] cement or carpet i
don't give a [ __ ] what it is
you know but it's letting me know that
when it's all said and done
if you ever want to encounter
a transformation in that area
you know where i'm at and if you don't
believe me take me up on
it i got you i'll be right here waiting
on you
thank you
was that good nobody talks like you
nobody what's it good
though man it's [ __ ] great okay
okay better and better
you're amazing